this problem is from chapter five of the
cots trickle and townsend chemistry and
chemical reactivity textbook so they
tell us suppose you want to know the
enthalpy change so the change in total
energy for the formation of methane ch4
from solid carbon as graphite that's
right there and hydrogen gas so we want
to figure out the enthalpy change of
this reaction how do we get methane how
much energy is absorbed or released when
methane is formed from the reaction of
solid carbon is graphite and hydrogen
gas so they tell us the enthalpy change
for this reaction cannot be measured in
the laboratory because the reaction is
very slow so normally if you could
measure it you would have this reaction
happening and you would kind of see how
much heat or what's the temperature
change of the surrounding solution maybe
this is happening so slow that it's very
hard to measure that temperature change
or you can't do it in any meaningful way
we can however measure enthalpy changes
for the combustion of carbon hydrogen
and methane so they're giving us the
enthalpy changes for these combuction
combustion reactions is combustion of
carbon combustion of hydrogen combustion
of methane and they say use this
information to calculate the change in
enthalpy for the formation of methane
from its elements so anytime you see
this kind of situation where they're
giving you the enthalpies for a bunch of
reactions and they say hey we don't know
the enthalpy for some other reaction and
that other reaction seems to be made up
of similar things your brain should
immediately say hey maybe this is a
hess's law problem
hess is
hesse's law and all hess's law says is
that if a reaction is the sum of two or
more other reactions then the change in
enthalpy of this reaction is going to be
the sum of the change in enthalpies of
those reactions now when we look at this
this and this tends to be the confusing
part is how can you construct this
reaction out of these reactions over
here and what i like to do is just start
with the end product so i like to start
with the end product which is methane in
a gaseous form and when we look at all
of these equations over here
we have the combustion of methane so
this actually involves methane so let's
start with this but this one involves
methane as a reactant not a product but
what we can do is just flip this arrow
and write it as methane as a product so
if we just write this reaction we flip
it so now we have carbon dioxide gas
carbon dioxide gas let me write down
here carbon dioxide
gas
plus
plus i'll do this in another color plus
two
plus two waters plus two
if we're thinking of these as moles or
two molecules of water you could even
say two molecules of water in its liquid
state
that can i guess you can say that you
know this would not happen spontaneously
because it would require energy but if
we just put this in the reverse
direction if you go in this direction
you're going to get two waters i'll do
that in a different or two oxygens i
should say i'll do that in this pink
color so two
two oxygens plus
and that's in its gaseous state plus a
gaseous methane
plus a gaseous methane so plus a gaseous
methane
ch4
ch4 in a gaseous state and all i did is
i wrote this this third equation but i
wrote it in reverse order i'm going from
the reactants to the product so if i'm
going from there when you go from the
product to the reactants it will release
890.3 kilojoules per moles of the
reaction
going on but if you go the other way it
will need 890 kilojoules so the delta h
here
i'll do this in a neutral color so the
delta h
the delta h of this reaction right here
is going to be the reverse of this so
it's 800 it's positive 890.3
kilojoules kilojoules per mole of the
reaction
all i did is i reversed the order of
this reaction right there the good thing
about this is i now have something at
least ends up with what we eventually
want to end up with this is this is
where we want to get
this is where we want to get eventually
now how if we want to get there
eventually we need to at some point have
some carbon dioxide we have to have at
some point some water to deal with so
how can we get carbon dioxide and how
can we get water well these two
reactions right here this combustion
reaction gives us carbon dioxide this
combustion reaction gives us water so we
can just rewrite those let me just
rewrite them over here and i'll
i will
i will let me use some colors so if i
start with
graphite carbon in graphite form so
carbon
in its graphite form plus i already have
a color for oxygen
plus oxygen
plus
oxygen in its gaseous state it will
produce carbon dioxide in its gaseous
form
it will produce carbon no that's a
different shade of green it will produce
carbon dioxide in its gaseous form and
this reaction so when you take the the
enthalpy of the carbon dioxide and from
that you subtract the enthalpy of these
reactants you get a negative number
which means this had a lower enthalpy
which means energy was released because
there's now less energy in the system
right here so this this is essentially
how much is released but our change in
enthalpy here
our change in enthalpy of this reaction
right here that's reaction one i'll just
rewrite it minus 393.5
kilojoules
kilojoules per mole
for or per mole of the reaction
occurring so the reaction occurs a mole
times it would this would be the amount
of energy that's essentially released
this is our change in enthalpy so if
this happens we'll get our carbon
dioxide now we also have and so we would
release this much energy and we'd have
this product to deal with but we also
now need our water so and this reaction
right here gives us our water the
combustion of hydrogen
so we have and i had i haven't done
hydrogen yet so let me do hydrogen a new
color
that's not a new color
so let me do
blue
so right here you have hydrogen gas i'm
just rewriting that reaction hydrogen
gas plus
one half o2 pink is my color for oxygen
one half
o2
gas
will yield will give us some water will
give us
h2o
will give us some
liquid water will give us some liquid
wire now before before i just write this
number down let's think about whether we
have everything we need to make this
reaction occur because this gets us to
our final product this gets us to the
gaseous methane we need a mole or we can
even say a molecule of carbon dioxide
and this reaction gives us exactly one
molecule of carbon dioxide so that's a
check and we need two molecules of water
now this reaction only gives us one
molecule of water so let's multiply both
sides of the equation to get two
molecules of water so this is a two we
multiply this this by two so this
essentially just disappears you multiply
one half by two you just get a one there
and then you put a two over here so i
just multiplied this second equation by
two so i just multiply this this becomes
a one this becomes a two and if you're
doing twice as much of it because we
multiply it by 2 the delta h now the
change in enthalpy of the reaction
is now going to be twice this let's get
the calculator out
it's going to be
it's now going to be negative 285.8
times 2
because we just multiplied the whole
reaction times 2. so negative 571.6
so it's negative 571.6
kilojoules per mole
of the reaction
now let's see if the combination if the
sum of these reactions actually is this
reaction up here actually is this
reaction up here and to do that actually
let me just copy and paste this top one
here because that's kind of the order
that we're going to go in
but you don't have to but it just makes
it hopefully a little bit easier to
understand
so let me just copy and paste this
actually i could cut and paste it
cut and then let me paste it
down here that first one and let's see
now what's going to happen
let's see
what's going to happen and to see
whether the sum of these reactions
really does end up being this top
reaction right here let's see if we can
cancel out reactants and products or
let's see what would happen so this
produces carbon dioxide but then this
mole or this molecule of carbon dioxide
is then used up in this last reaction so
this produces it this uses it so those
cancel out let me do it in the same
color so it's in this green this
reaction produces it this reaction uses
it
now this reaction right here produces
the two molecules of water and now this
reaction down here i want to do that
same color
it's two molecules of water now this
reaction down here uses those two
molecules of water
now these this reaction right here it
requires one molecule of molecular
oxygen this one requires another
molecule of molecular oxygen so these
two combined
these two combined are two molecules of
molecular oxygen so those are the
reactants and in the end those end up as
the products of this last reaction so
those actually they go into the system
and then they leave out the system or
out of this the sum of reactions
unchanged so they cancel out with each
other so we could say that and that we
cancel out and so what are we left with
what are we left with in the reaction
well we have some solid carbon as
graphite plus two moles or two molecules
of hydrogen molecular hydrogen yielding
all we have left on the product side is
some methane so it is true that the sum
of these reactions is
exactly what we want all we have left on
the product side is the graphite
the solid graphite plus the molecular
hydrogen plus the gaseous hydrogen
do it in that color plus two
hydrogen
gas and all we have left on the product
side all we have left on the product
side is the methane
all we have left is the methane in the
gaseous form so it is true that the sum
of these reactions remember we had to
flip this reaction around and change its
sign and we had to multiply this
reaction by 2 so that the sum of these
becomes this reaction that we really
care about so since this is the sum of
these reactions its change in enthalpy
its change in enthalpy
its change in enthalpy of this reaction
is going to be the sum of these right
here that is hess's law
so this is the fun part so we just add
up these values right here so we have
negative 393 point no that's not what i
wanted to do
let me just clear it
so i have
negative
393.5 so that step is exothermic
and then we have minus
571.6 that is also exothermic those are
both combustion reactions which are as
we know very exothermic and then we have
the endothermic step the reverse of that
last combustion reaction so plus 890.3
plus 890.3
gives us
negative 74.8
it gives us negative 74 74.8
kilojoules
for every mole of the reaction occurring
or the reaction occurs a mole times so
there you go we figured out the change
in enthalpy and it is reasonably it is
reasonably exothermic nowhere near as
exothermic as these combustion reactions
right here but it is going to release it
is going to release energy and we're
done